[Music]
so let's talk about spinning one poi and
going deep with that dig musically I'm
going to do harm and sing for you for
this so again you can't pull these all
to build a foundation and building up on
top of that face much like this great
Cathedral and apparently it's a big
foundation in the bottom and then you
build them yeah I know I'm almost
quoting Jesus here but you know why not
right so build your poi on a good
foundation so that comes back to one
point and really becoming free and
having fun musically with one poi so
that means that once you can be like
okay I can cross boards and I can cross
backwards good can we do all the tricks
now no it doesn't work that way no no
you have to really go into it so for
instance this is just playing with one
poi right but you can play like you're
dancing you can move and spin like
you're dancing you can make it a fun
game and it can be expressive and I'm
making these earlier except I know it's
a little strange but if you can play
like this and people might think you're
deranged but you will deeply learn how
to move the poi from your Center and
then when you add a second poi it'll
work and you can enter
you know more point moves so play and
let me know how that goes oh my friends
have arrived yay